structured query language sql or sql for
short is the gold standard language for
communicating with relational database
management systems you've likely heard
of databases like mysql
postgres microsoft sql server and oracle
all of which are based on sql with their
own little variations
it was initially developed in the early
70s to mutate and retrieve data from
ibm's system r database by 1986
it was standardized into the syntax that
remains extremely popular in technical
applications today a relational database
organizes data into tables
kind of like an excel spreadsheet where
columns contain attributes or types of
data
while each row represents an individual
record or data point with its own unique
id
known as a primary key we can establish
relationships between data points
by taking the unique id from one row and
storing it on a different row in a
different table
in a special column known as a foreign
key in the teams table the team id
is the primary key but in the players
table it's the foreign key
and what that data structure tells us is
that a player belongs to one team
while a team can have many players what
we've done here
is structured our data in its smallest
normal form to eliminate duplication and
redundancy
now the role of sql is not only to read
create
update and delete data but also to join
data together
based on the relationships embedded
within it the syntax
is comprised of several key parts if we
zoom all the way out
we have a statement or a piece of code
that does something
like reads or writes to the database
within a statement we have a variety of
keywords that can manipulate the
database
select can be used to make a query for
the columns that you want
from a table the column and table names
are known as
identifiers but we may not want every
row in the table so we filter the
results with the where keyword to only
include records that meet a certain
condition
it's like looping over every row in the
table and only returning rows in the
query where the predicate evaluates to
true
then we might use the join keyword to
connect data from an entirely different
table
by matching the primary key on this
table to the foreign key on another
table
what we've created is a collection of
clauses that make up
a full sql statement we can now go and
execute this code on the hundreds of
different databases that support
sql this has been structured query
language in 100 seconds
like and subscribe if you want to see a
full sql tutorial
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one